pénélope seuls 21 ans de chair il y en
avoir il ya 24 ans est troisième
anne-sophie jantes 18 ans attaquant que
recherche
tokai mtnd feuillage aux play off the
wall
et long cou une équipe de pongistes haï
pour gagner de pénélope saul l'enfant du
club et yanan wang fille de championne
du monde a lieu cet été le talent ne
manque pas et cette saison la mayonnaise
élan courtoise prend huit amis dans la
vie anne-sophie bien année maria
habitants colocation et sont presque
inséparables ouais parce qu'on te parle
beaucoup et après on pivot et trouvait
une très bonne ambiance en profite c'est
très bien pour l'équipe oui c'est vrai
qu'ils pensent que nous en soit
tous les jours à l'entraînement rigole
bien on essaye de faire des choses entre
nous on doit super sympa
pour la première fois le club et l'on
courtois proton charge l'équipe à 100%
fini l'on tente avec marly-le-roi un
palier passé avec un renfort de choix
maria christophe aura acquis la numéro 1
grecque qui partage son temps entre
elles en cours et le championnat suédois
le club m'a fait une belle proposition
je voulais jouer dans un bon championnat
plus compétitif que la grèce parce que
le championnat grec n'a pas un bon
niveau et l'opportunité de jouer ici
était très intéressante
entraîneur proche de ses filles franks
on y apprend à gérer les égos de
sécheuse avec diplomatie je veux les
avoir toutes les quatre ensemble si j'ai
des choses à leur dire je leur dis aux 4
je pense que l'autorité chez les filles
marchent moins bien grave chez les
garçons on peut être cash il n'y a pas
de problème il nous en rendrons pas le
lendemain on se reparle saint jour pour
les filles il faut faut être un peu plus
dans le consensus comme l'équipe de
franck sony joue le maintien en pro b
cette saison tombé dans une poule très
relevée chaque match sera décisif à
commencer par ce mardi soir avec la
réception de mulhouse pour confirmer la
belle victoire de la première jeunes